governor sissel acts big spending spree
today he held an unusual off-year state
of the state speech the governor
outlined more than one billion dollars
in new programs while drawing sharp
criticism from the republican side
politics now host john langler was
inside a legion stadium for this event
1.8 billion dollars that's how much
federal pandemic relief money governor
sisalik has to spend across nevada today
we learned where most of it will go for
governor steve sisilak allegiant stadium
is the culmination of what's right in
nevada and why he says the future is
positive quite simply because of you the
state of our state is resilient and
getting stronger every day normally
these speeches only happen before a
legislative session this year there
isn't one what there is is a huge pot of
money the governor plans to spread
around the state ultimately this is
about making life better for the people
we love governor sisolak has 1.8 billion
dollars in federal pandemic relief money
at his disposal today he revealed plans
to spend it proposals include 500
million dollars on affordable housing
500 million dollars on high speed
internet 160 million dollars for child
care four billion dollars for roads
incentives for teachers and pay raises
for nevada state police that's real
progress but we can't let up senate
republican leader james settlemyer was
unimpressed spending money is not
leadership this money will be spent to
grow the government size but with no
thought of how to fund that growth when
the money is gone governor sisolak and
his team say almost all of those
proposals are actionable meaning they
would get through interim committees up
in carson city and he's also pledged no
new taxes john langler live local now